[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
g
ge
salut les amis du ça va bien ça va ça va
et toi sandrine un centre in le
portemanteau extraterrestre ça va bien
ça les amuse clarisse et bassa de
lindebeuf marteau voilà
sandrine sans quoi je sens que tu vas
encore de donner une mission c'est voir
ramené à mâcher des gestes parce qu'il
faut protéger la tête des forces du mal
et ce pour ça que vous rappelle que vous
pouvez retrouver les six banques est
magique qu'il faut un champ de force
autour du studio de la plaine
saint-denis tabernacle bandits dont
sébastien est difficile comment on va
faire je sais pas comment on va faire
autrement
en tout cas on va chercher mais d'abord
on regarde une super série c'est cynthia
hulu le rythme de la vie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que c'était que ça qu'est bon
allez on retrouve tout de suite une
autre super série dans le club jdg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya bien un type de série dont on n'a
jamais parlé c'est bien les afin aussi
en fait on en a parlé plusieurs fois
mais on va en parler c'est les séries de
sport
[Musique]
alors déjà il faut différencier les deux
types majeurs de séries sportives on a
les séries occidentales et les séries
japonaises alors les séries japonaises
c'est tout le temps pareil et les séries
occidentale c'est n'importe quoi
voilà alors on fait quoi les séries
occidentale de sport ça date pas d'hier
par exemple dans les années 70 il y
avait des aventures de mohamed ali où il
se bat contre des loups garous et oui tu
vas dans l'espace qui sait peut-être
qu'un jour on aura les aventures de
ribéry qui voyagent un temps il y avait
aussi pro stars avec michael jordan ou
wayne gretzky et l'autre je sais plus
qui sait où ces trois stars de ce sport
qui aide des enfants d'ailleurs c'est là
tout l'art des séries américaines où ils
utilisent toujours des stars et je sais
pas pourquoi il est toujours des enfants
enfin bref nous en france on avec des
fois les mêmes genre de truc mais nous
c'était avec carlos bon c'est moins
classe
d'une manière générale les séries
occidentales sont toujours composés de
stand alone c'est à dire d'un seul
épisode on retrouve des trucs comme par
exemple le week-end une série de foot
dans le basket les kangoo et ça fait
partie de ce que j'appelle les séries
n'importe quoi parce que bon je viens tu
pourrais remplacer les kangoo par des
humains ça passerait aussi c'est juste
les kangourous parce qu'il voulait
absolument faire la vanne ou alors c'est
des kangourous alors ça saute haut
le joueur de basket donc c'est drôle
compris pourquoi c'est drôle non pour
moi la seule conséquence de ça c'est que
ça rend la série hyper malsaine car ils
se font draguer la part l'autre blonde
laquelle visiblement tout le temps les
ovaires au bord de l'explosion
alors je sais pas j'ai peut-être perdu
mon âme d'enfant mais vous n'avez pas un
million d'image dégueulasse qui vous
viennent à l'esprit quand vous voyez ça
maintenant falloir d'une manière
générale ce genre de série était
vraiment typique des séries occidentale
et elle est pour moi un exemple parlant
c'est la comparaison entre la série
sonic x fait au japon et la série les
aventures de sonic qui est franco
américaine
la seconde est clairement destiné à un
public plus jeune et ça se voit mais les
séries occidental ces salles sont faites
pour des gens plus jeunes ou plus
stupide
ça dépend comme on se place
contrairement aux séries japonaises qui
elle était fait pour des gens malsains
pas pareil c'est mieux évidemment quand
on parle de ses rideaux stores japonaise
le premier truc auquel tout le monde
pense c'est olive et tom
on en a parlé les terrains trop long la
lutte contre la souffrance roberto
carlos qui habite visiblement chez la
mère d'olivier pendant que le père
d'olivier est bloqué en mer pendant à
peu près 200 épisodes
c'est angoissant un moment tu penses
vraiment avoir peur pour lui chaque fois
qu'il apparaît à l'image il a son bateau
immobile perdu quelque part en l'air ou
coincé près d'un glacier quoi moi avait
franchement vers l'épisode 100 je
m'attendais à tout moment à ce
qu'olivier refaire un truc comme ça
mon très cher olivier cela fait 2 178
jours que notre bateau est tombé en
panne hier j'ai mangé le dernière êtres
humains il n'y a plus d'eau et j'ai du
mal à respirer
bisous
papa moi ce qui me faisait beaucoup rire
dans cette série c'est que jusque là ils
doivent avoir un problème au japon ils
sont pas du tout impressionnée par des
trucs de fou
[Musique]
et par contre ils sont super
impressionné par des trucs de merde
[Musique]
[ __ ] je parie que vous n'auriez jamais
imaginé qu'on puisse se faire des passes
olive et tom c'est quand même une série
qui nous a appris des choses par exemple
le ballon est ton meilleur ami est ton
meilleur ami tu lui défonce arras à
coups de pied ç'a vraiment j'adorais et
j'adore toujours d'ailleurs cette série
mais il y avait des moments j'avais
vraiment envie de hurler sur ma télé
pour faire avancer l'histoire l'a
surtout comment pendant les matches qui
faisait leur flash back ou leurs
monologues intérieurs pendant qu'il
remontait le terrain
surtout que ben flashback ça devrait
plutôt ressembler à ça en fait quand ils
pensent
il verra ce que 18 secondes pour à
montayral mettre un but je dois le faire
pour tous mes amis et pour ce qu'ils ont
fait pour moi c'est maintenant que je
dois marquer des buts
fortement équipe putois est donc toute
l'histoire est évidemment celle
d'olivier qui arrive dans une nouvelle
ville et qui rencontre thomas sur un
terrain de foot où différents clubs se
disputent pour obtenir le terrain et je
réalise qu'en fait je dis absolument
n'importe quoi parce que c'est un
terrain de foot
à quoi ça va leur servir d'avoir un
terrain de foot à ceux qui font du du
baseball qui est peut-être très fort et
tu deviendras pas celle là puisque vous
aimez faire de ce terrain
[Applaudissements]
mais retourner dans vos clubs sa balle
est tellement sûr de toi et prétentieux
que j'ai hâte de voir ce que tu fais
c'est n'importe quoi il a même pas de
poteaux de rugby sur sa maintenant c'est
à moi la capitaine du club des snacks et
maintenant c'est à moi capitaine du club
de water-polo
je vais gagner ce terrain pour enfin je
vais gagner ce terrain et puis bon
autant des fois c'est juste un peu
bizarre autant des fois ce dessin lui
mais il a quand même une bonne morale de
merde je suppose que vous souvenez de
roulis andros le joueur cardiaque et
bien son infarctus il finit enfin par le
faire à l'épisode 64
qu'est ce qui t'arrive qu'est ce qui s'y
passe
regardez auxerre qui dit il y note de
leur dette
je le vois une explication aux livres
yanez royal
depuis tous les sens il a évidemment le
jeu s'arrête et tous ses coéquipiers se
précipitent pour l'aider continue à
jouer un continuel arbitres n'a pas
sifflé et et enfin soit parce que le
ballon est pas sorti qu'il faut était de
jouer il va mourir
alala lions s'est introduit sur le
terrain est en train de dévorer les
gauches malheureusement le ballon
n'étant pas sorti arbitres ne peut pas
sifflé
c'est mieux de nous donner un coup de
main au lieu de t'occuper de louis way
laisse le creux mais c'est juste notre
être humain ta question d'arrêter je
suis sûr qu'ils ne voudraient pas regard
boulianne je vais marquer un but rien
pour toi
arrêtez de parler de lui comme s'il
était mort et le pire c'est que mark
landers qui est le seul à être resté à
côté de lui pour s'assurer qu'il va bien
se fait engueuler après tu ne te serais
jamais comporter de cette façon dans les
mêmes circonstances il y a un an et
l'honnêteté de l'admettre qui aurait
continué à jouer sans se soucier de cet
incident comme tes coéquipiers
ouais que changer aille à une époque où
la vie humaine n'avait aucune valeur
pour toi et maintenant regarde toi tu es
devenu une de ces espèces de connards de
bobos gauchistes l'ap
et pendant ce temps là dans le monde
cynthia et le rythme de la vie
[Musique]
une autre série de foot très connu en
france c'est évidemment
[Musique]
voilà maintenant je suis sûr que vous
allez chantonnay ça toute la journée ce
générique qui se gravent dans la tête
c'est un truc de fou
l'école des champions une série de 91
qui reprend finalement un peu les mêmes
recettes que olive et tom joueur très
bon qui arrive dans une équipe de nuls
hausse avec tous les clichés habituels
ya les intellos il ya le goal un peu nul
sérieusement quand même est-ce que c'est
pas le pire casting du monde pour un
goal j'ai dit [ __ ] il fait 70 cm de
haut le mec
bref après c'est le topo habituel
rencontre rivale kim a affronté mon dieu
qu'est ce que c'est que c'est énorme
faute
vous savez je crois que les japonais en
fait ils n'ont pas compris le principe
du foot en fait je crois qu'ils se
disent que tant qu'elle le ballon entre
ton pied le visage de l'adversaire ça va
c'est pas une faute même si tu as le
pied à un mètre cinquante du sol et que
tu te tente de tuer l'adversaire avec
des crampes aux si ça touche le ballon
il n'y a pas faute bon allé de son va
pas passer des heures sur cette série et
c'est une très bonne série d'ailleurs
mais en gros c'est juste bon tu prends
olive et tom
tu prends cette musique tu donnes des
noms totalement raciste aux gens
[ __ ] quel parent appellerez son fils
macaronis je m'excuse si des gens
s'appelle réellement macaronis je ne
suis pas au fait de la culture italienne
sauf pour les pâtes au pesto je m'excuse
également cédé jean s'appelle pâte au
resto bref ensuite tu rajoutes un
triangle amoureux nul et voilà tu à
l'école des champions
alors passons directement à la fin de la
série c'est la grande finale ya un super
match qui dure trois épisodes avec un
défilé de techniques courantes dans le
foot comme par exemple le double coup de
pied dans un ballon la double retourné
acrobatique dans un ballon la talonnade
retourner en saut acrobatique avant l'
esquive de tacles en saut acrobatique
arrière suivie d'un coup de pied de
notre sol acrobatiques arrière la
défense de buts en double saut
acrobatique la discussion des
entraîneurs au bord du terrain avec eux
qui à son tu as l'air on n'est pas bien
avec les gènes hla aux [ __ ] annoncé son
pantalon j'ai rien dit bref la prise de
ballon en faisant ça
quelques dizaines de flashbacks oui je
suis et comment ses amis sont trop sympa
et on finit par benjamin qui luttent
seul face à environ 278 défenseurs et
c'est le but
enfin et donc le final et larmoyant le
moment où les rivaux fraternisent mon
relève son adversaire au sol pour
finalement célébrer la joie du sport
tous ensemble la fin de cette série
émouvante merveilleuse dit tous les amis
réunis pour le long de la plage des
larmes sont versées mais ce sont des
larmes d'hommes et pas nous sommes
accusés de tricherie le match et est
considéré comme nul
tout est à recommencer [ __ ]
sérieusement se servent à rien de faire
monter toute cette émotion si c'est pour
tout annuler après
cet endroit est vraiment magnifique
attend déjà vu cette scène et méo ça
aussi
j'ai déjà vu ça ils ont réutilisé
uniquement des images d'anciens épisodes
pour monter les trois derniers épisodes
j'ai déjà vu ça et le but final de la
deuxième finale
c'est exactement le même que dans
l'épisode 49 pourquoi pourquoi ils ont
fait ça je comprends pas et expliquer
mon bien il se trouve que cette série
est une collaboration franco japonaise
qui s'est mal passé les japonais où il
ya des livres et 52 épisodes maman livré
que 49 coup quand le réalisateur
français entre du japon il a dû bricoler
trois épisodes à partir de boues
récupérées dans les séries en
s'inspirant aussi de l'histoire de
bernard tapie
[Musique]
bartoli et maintenant on retrouve le fil
rouge de cette émission
et pendant ce temps-là nom de dieu est
ce qui va se passer un truc dans cette
[ __ ] de série
tenez une anecdote de tournage quand on
a préparé cette émission on a regardé
trois épisodes de cynthia à la suite
et quand bien même en tout ça devait
faire 30 ou 40 minutes on a continué à
bâiller pendant les sept heures qui ont
suivi c'est véridique je veux dire cette
série elle aspire votre énergie vitale
tellement qui s'y passe rien quelque
part le titre est bien trouvée c'est
vraiment le rythme de la vie et la vie
bah c'est un peu chiant des fois c'est
genre souvent il se passe rien n'y a pas
de musique tu attends cette série c'est
exactement ça c'est uniquement des
situations normales des choses banales
des des longs silences et en fait la
seule série de sports que j'ai vu avec
rien d'exceptionnel tout est normal
enfin je suis curieux quand même parce
que sur la boîte y est marquée en point
d'orgue une conclusion audacieuse et
surprenante à s'auto dernier épisode
alors aux fins de toute façon vu ce
qu'il y avait avant mon avis ça va être
un truc complètement bateau et j'en
connais pas tu participera au
championnat du monde
tu affrontera marier toutes les
meilleures ginai rencontrer son double
du futur quoi mais oui c'est
complètement son double du futur qui
vient lui annoncer son destin mais
comment avez vous fait pour lire dans
mes pensées
vous êtes magicienne et comme tout les
magiciennes je garde mes secrets il faut
que tu continues la gym sinon voilà ce
qui va t'arriver
bon c'est trop mou la envoyez moi un
truc qui bouge envoyez moi un truc pour
mec tu y as du tennis donnez moi du
tennis
[Musique]
alors aux normes et axway
bonnac jana
[Musique]
non
quand
[Musique]
bon ok alors envoyez moi - de tennis
mais non un peu moins de tennis s'il
vous plaît et un peu moins d'effets
spéciaux aussi qu'est ce que c'est que
ce truc à dire et lady oscar qui fait du
tennis mais qui aurait été dessiné avec
un effet de kaléidoscope hippiques donc
jeu set et match c'est une série avec un
peu tennis beaucoup d'histoires d'amour
que je n'ai absolument pas regarder
parce que c'était vraiment trop chiant
et beaucoup trop girly pour moi je veux
dire il ya vraiment beaucoup trop des
toiles pour moi dans cette scène là on
dirait sonic quand il est en mode est
mince il observé alors pour le peu que
j'ai regardé cette série c'est le
classique
[ __ ] c'est quoi ce à quoi ce qui des
fantômes sur le terrain de votre nouvel
entraîneur jean mallet
en fait il ça je crois que les
dessinateurs n'avait pas vraiment envie
de dessiner les personnages secondaires
et du coup ils ont créé ces espèces de
trucs qui sont d'autant plus bizarre que
parfois ils sont même pas en
arrière-plan
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
flippant bon alors puisque oneda les
dessins animés pour filles autant y
rester il existe un dessin animé de
sport comme olive et tom qui a provoqué
un engouement massif pour son sport
lorsqu'il est sorti et c'est évidemment
arrêté de sourire je vois votre sourire
nostalgique mais vous devez savoir des
choses sur jade donc l'histoire commence
dans l'école on retrouve john woo qui
tâche et sur une arbre qui cherche son
petit frère et tullow pardon c'est un
réflexe je mesure qui qui visiblement
est un esprit de la forêt puisqu'elle a
le pouvoir de parler aux animaux
donc j'en vois au loin un match de
volley et puis tu [ __ ] en fait jane c
naruto [ __ ] bref elle fonce vers la
page the we own the et retrouve son
frère qui regarde un match de volley
mais qui s'enfuit parce qu'il a
terriblement envie de pisser finalement
ne pouvant se retenir il pisse au milieu
du terrain de volley et la jeanne nous
montre quelle grande soeur magnifique
elle fait tu es vraiment mal élevés
ouais bon ok vous de lui
moquez vous du petit enfant qui vient de
se pisser dessus donc après s'être
libéré de sa séquestration
parce que oui si vous pisser sur un
terrain de volley au japon vous attache
dans une cave
même si vous avez six ans jeanne rentrer
chez elle et prend une bonne douche
pendant qu'un son frère croupit dans ses
vêtements trempés de peace puis ensuite
j'en lis une lettre effet un flash back
sur le fait qu'elle aurait préféré que
son frère soit un chaton et ont conclu
de ce passage par lee chan voilà c'est
ça l'héroïne de voler vous avez aimé un
monstre et c'est pas fini
bref maintenant on retrouve les filles
du club de volley ball qui ont gagné
leur match par 15 à eux nous avons gagné
la partie
ah bah oui d'ailleurs la version dvd est
très cool pour ça parce qu'il ya plein
de choses qu'on voit qui rend cette
série est incroyablement cruel surtout
tous les délires qui a autour de
l'entraîneur put ainsi se passe ça pour
un point alors qu'elles ont gagné il se
passe quoi qu allait perdre le match
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regardez c'est horrible colas à la nana
à poil en train de saigner de pleurer
sous la douche après s'être fait
tabasser par son entraîneur stan mer
mais le coup de pied
bref on s'éloigne et retour à l'épisode
on retrouve donc janot outil qui
arrivent à l'école en défonçant même eu
un portail en fer et qui rappelle à son
petit frère qui l'a suivi que ce n'est
pas vraiment sa soeur et moi seul il ne
faut pas mentir tu sais très bien que je
ne suis pas ta soeur je ne suis pas ta
soeur tes parents sont morts c'est
compris à cause de toi c'est pas m
est-ce que vous avez encore le moindre
respect pour jeanne maintenant après un
passage par le club où elle montre
qu'elle est très forte jeanne ans rentre
à la maison rencontre son père qui l'a
abandonné je rappelle il ya sept ans
probablement pour pour une secte je
pense que je trouve que le personnage il
ressemble à mort à didier bourdon dans
le sketch de la secte ou des inconnus
que ça vous à la ts riches nous et là
bon c'est un peu incompréhensible dans
la vo normalement jeanne gifle son père
bon sa mère l'abandonné pour faire du
volley son père l'a abandonné pour faire
des photos puis à adopter un gamin qu'il
a de nouveau abandonné pour le confier à
sa fille qu'il avait abandonnée
précédemment bon je peux comprendre y
avait les boules
enfin je suis assez normal ça donne une
dimension humaine au personnage me vois
pas le problème mais mais c'est
complètement censuré dans la vfb ça
ressemble à ça
[Musique]
papa c'est toi oui c'est moi ma fille je
suis rentré je suis tellement heureux
que nous soyons réunis après sept
longues années
enfin pour en revenir à jeanne et à ses
superpouvoirs chaque épisode est un peu
comme ça de toute manière dans l'épisode
2 je vous jure qu'on dirait que ça va
partir un truc de super héros il ya au
début il ya deux mecs qui se font
agresser et puis là qui sait qui arrive
est allé floch la logique est maintenant
elles arrêtent des motos à mains nues
voilà il ya toujours ce délire avec les
animaux c'est d'ailleurs cette série
elle a vraiment une morale absolument
dégueulasse celle des fois je vais
revenir à l'entraîneur dimon épisode 13
donc l'épisode commence par jeunes qui
défonce arras son petit frère avec un
ballon pour essayer son nouveau service
canon et qui me dit que c'est pas le
contraire mais ça n'est pas le sujet des
pilotes l'histoire donc se passe à
l'école ou au bout d'un moment et
notamment parce qu'il gifler ses
joueuses en public et devant les caméras
la direction de l'établissement ludique
bon ce nom le patro possible de faire ce
genre de choses hein monsieur oui
évidemment que oui oui ça se sert d'un
précieux c'est le premier accès de bon
sens de la série évidemment que ça se
fait pas de taper des enfants il vient
de découvrir ça et lui maintient que non
ce soit ma nière d'apprendre de volley
ball mais regardez sa tête
je vais vous défoncer et après je
rentrerai chez moi pour taper ma femme
donc bien l'entraîneur refusant de
changer ses méthodes jeanne pas revoir
dans d'autres clubs pour voir comment il
s'entraîne d'ailleurs donc dans le
premier club on tabasse les gens au sol
dans le second club les filles sont
torturés à l'aide d'un superordinateur
jeudi rage de super à cette série monk
que les violences sexuelles pour avoir
le combo est justement à la fin de
l'épisode 16 janssen l'ange de cognac
bref voyant tous âges jeunes revient au
club et se met à genoux et implore
l'entraîneur de le de l'attraper quoi et
c'est la morale de cette histoire un
quand on a des convictions il faut les
suivre jusqu'au bout
même quand ça implique de taper des
enfants aller j'accorde un bon point à
jeanne quand même parce qu'elle a essayé
de se rebeller contre les bandes et
contre ses méthodes pour essayer de
protéger les autres filles de l'équipe
donc ça veut dire qu'elle n'est pas si
mauvaise que ça finalement
[Musique]
tout le monde se moque de moi je me
moque de moi parce que je sais pas nager
au lieu de pleurnicher pourquoi ne tue
pas à la piscine pour apprendre à nager
une bonne fois pour toutes il veut ok
j'ai rien dit c'est une [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]